you kissed him totally baby are you
serious
yeah I'm just in there he came and he
introduced himself and then next thing I
know wouldn't make out see I mean you do
know he's married no what am I supposed
to do ask every guy make out with if
he's married
no here I should ladies you've been
killing it as tik-tok saved you in the
quarantine yes I didn't want to join now
that I have I am like down the rabbit
hole
it's splinched fun same I couldn't even
want to join either honestly we always
teased my brother for using tech talk
and then once quarantine started I
hopped on the bandwagon and then a
couple weeks later she did too and it
just kind of weed Elvin where do you
come up with the ideas who's really the
creative brains behind it and does
anybody ever reject somebody else's idea
for a Tech Talk
Natacha the big word perfectionist
tonight so she rejects just about
everything true i we have to do it a
billion times so she can be absolutely
perfect yeah she but here's the thing if
I I feel like she rejects more ideas
like I'll say hey let's yeah this
charity Capri she's like no but then
once we actually do once we agree on you
know a specific type of what we want to
do I'm the one that's like needs to do
it a million times till it's perfect
yeah okay mom it's the rules do you have
a favorite one that you did together
Oprah sure the shits Creek with Moira
and David folding in the cheese sure
what's fold in the cheese mean you fold
- did I understand that but how do you
fold it do you fold it in half like a
piece of paper and drop it in the pot or
what do you do
I cannot show you everything okay well
can you show me one thing askew
sit outside it was the whole thing no
but I even had a wig on and everything
like I was going for it
natasha has there ever been a moment
she's your mom you love her and she
loves you but with the embarrassment
factor any tic TOCs she's done that have
embarrassed you that you've been like
mom why are you kidding yes there's one
guy literally you can hear me say in the
video I'm like I'm not gonna let you
post this like don't do this I don't do
this I don't know I really you know you
know like they all know I do this and I
was trying to do it with my mother
because my mom wanted to be on the chick
back so I was like mom let's do this one
just copy what I do and it was like no
I'm not it's so bad you know what after
I said okay here's that here's how you
do the dance better or whatever she's
like you know what no no just takes the
fun out of tick-tock we're just done she
left to trim a story true story Wow
right out of it for me grandma fun
sucking okay Natasha do you do you wish
you had posting approval like do you
need to be the yes/no person I don't
need posting approval but it is just
like some things are like you could be
the voice of reason you know and I
wanted to be the voice of reason you
know great but honestly my ticked off is
like random stuff so I well I think
you're gonna miss her when she goes off
to film this new movie
what is that gonna be like have they
told you guys how things will change
because of safety with the pandemic yeah
they're definitely new protocols that we
have to follow and the shooting
schedules are taking longer in general
active quarantine for two weeks before
we start but I'm feeling confident that
things will things will go well and I'm
excited to get back to work
Marilu Henner who plays my mom in the
Aurora Teagarden mysteries we are going
to quarantine
together so you're gonna see a lot of my
Instagram and her Instagram about us
coordinating together so we'll be the
only two people in in a home for two
weeks until we get to start production
is she going to be your new tik-tok
partner you know Judi Dench's on tic toc
she loves it I don't like the tick tock
is for all yes um will you be enlisting
her to help you with your signature
much-loved workouts yes
although me right now like she does a
lot of yoga and her physique is amazing
and so I might be learning a few things
from her I have to ask you a personal
question because I know so many people
are struggling with this have you been
dating it all in the quarantine is this
even an option how are you handling that
and no very short answer no it's I feel
like it's really hard obviously to I
mean just to meet people in LA in
general but during quarantine you're not
really leaving your house so the answer
is no but yeah I feel like we'll see
every once in a while you'll see on tick
tock like one story of where it went
really well that people met over zoom or
something and then the rest of it is
just
I am so alone right
[Music]